[موسيقى]
مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه مغلقه بحث خلالها
دعم منكوبي زلزال في شمال سوريا دون طرح
مشروع قرار لدعم عمل معابر حدوديه اضافيه
وافق النظام السوري على فتحها لادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه الى مناطق شمال غربي
سوريا وتسعى الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ودول اخرى الى دعم عمل النقاط الحدوديه
بقرار اممي وهي فكره رفضتها روسيا
واعتبرتها انتهاكا للسياده السوريه وساد
تباين في المواقف خلال الجلسه التي خصصت
لتصويت على قرار يلزم النظام السوري بفتح
المعابر امام قوافل الاغاثه الى شمال
سوريا وكان الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيريش قد اعلن ان فتحه نقطتين
عبور اضافيتين بين تركيا وشمال غربي سوريا
لادخال المساعدات سيكون لفتره اوليه مدتها
ثلاثه اشهر
وقد حث المندوب الفرنسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي نيكولا على استصدار قرار بموجب
الفصل السابع من ميثاق الامم المتحده اذا
واجهت الامم المتحده اي عراقيل عند
محاولتها ادخال المساعدات عبر معبري
السلامه والراعي الى الشمال السوري
ابلغنا مكتب تنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه انه
مستعد لاعاده نشر القوافل على نقاط العبور
الثلاثه المتاح الان معبر واحد واذا عملت
النقطه التان الاضافيتان بطريقه شفافه
ومستدامه لمده ثلاثه اشهر ودون اي عراقيل
على الاطلاق ومرت المساعدات فبها ونعمه
والا فانه على مجلس الامن ان يعود الى
العمل ويصدر قرارا بموجب الفصل السابع
وقبل ذلك كانت مندوبه في الولايات المتحده
دائما لدى الامم المتحده ليندا توماس جرين
فيلدز قد نشرت مجلس الامن الدولي التصديق
على فتح معبرين اضافيين في سوريا وقالت
جرين في لقاء مع شبكات ام اس ام بي سي
الاخباريه الامريكيه ان تاخير فتح مزيدا
من المعابر يعني موت مزيدا من الضحايا
ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
على مجلس الامن ان يتحرك بشكل عاجل لفتح
معبرين حدوديين اضافيين وقد سمعنا من منسق
الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده انه من المهم ان نفتح معابر
اضافيه لذات على مجلس الامن التحرك على
الفور نامل ان نتمكن من تحقيق ذلك